hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen addario
website online game pc schirm mir wurde
dass sie auch zugesichert das ist ja
sowas gibt valerio wie es bei mir mal
recht gut ankam ich bring euch mal eins
hier da war ich glaube ich schlecht oder
gut ich verlinke waren ein star jetzt
ist jedenfalls die website wieder
angesagt und ich sehe schon cologna
holte im haus und wipro länger und das
ist irgendwie auch don't run and other
snakes es ist ein bisschen an das spiel
snake von meinem alten nokia handy
angelehnt das habe ich gesagt als ich
sieben war ganz schön lang herrscht wird
eben einfach mal luca als nickname
einklicken of play und ihr seht schon
das wenig hallo ich sammle jetzt hier
diese kaka ein die fliegt auch ein
bisschen auf mich zu wenn ich in der
nähe bin und dann wird meine schlange
halt ein bisschen länger um ein gottes
er da hinten schnell und wenn andere
schlangen in mich rein fahren
explodieren die quasi sollen die teile
und ich kann die dann quasi auf es und
wer dadurch wieder länger und ich kann
die linke maustaste gedrückt halten um
buch zu bekommen und pretty mama ich bin
dann da bin ich jetzt nämlich gerade tut
und er ist jetzt nämlich das auf und ich
wieso ist das jetzt auf einmal weg alles
er hat mir von angezeigt ist meine
finale länge ca 136 war das versuchen
jetzt einfach mal zu toppen oh mein gott
ich bin schon wieder so schnell wie
lange kann ich dann im bus ok jetzt ist
er vorbei leicht es sinnvoll gewesen
dass sich die maus einfach ausgestellt
hätte das ding ist allerdings dass ich
nicht weiß wie das geht kann ich mich
eigentlich selber irgendwie
komm ich total behindert gerade oh mein
gott
das hat er ganz schön stark gelöst
gerade ich glaube wenn man das hier
länger zog dann kann man wirklich echt
coole taktiken in diesem game entwickeln
ich bin allerdings schlecht ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich durch die skalierung des
videos hier weil das ja nicht perfekter
hd master hat dieses spiel ob ich da
durch irgendwas aus schneidet wie
beispielsweise oben links den chat oder
oben rechts ist leaderboard oder unten
rechts zitate oder unten links meine
aktuelle länge
das tut mir leid falls dies der fall
sein sollte
oh mein gott hol sie dir luca hole sich
hinein nein du blöde verfügte touch
lange das waren meine aber so langweilig
noch nie tatsächlich und man habe ich
kein extra eine richtig coole taktik
angewandt wie ich den beide kaputt
machen wie groß sind die denn hier alle
dass ich ja fast schon schlimmer als die
black mamba das ist ein bisschen
langweiliger als agrio aber dann wird es
ganz plötzlich auf einmal spannend bei
dario bahn sich das ja so an dass nicht
mehr leute verfolgen und alles und hier
ist es einfach nur so dann kommt auf
aber der schlanke vorderseite wright und
glaubt ihr alle da sagt was ist das denn
was ist denn das ist der stein der
weisen wie stein der weisen ist keine
angst habe er keine ahnung ich bin eine
schlange aber bleibt hier was genau
bringt
ich bin enttäuscht ich werde in diesem
spiel nie so gut sein wie ich in nagano
bin obwohl ich bin in nagano gar nicht
gut tut es halt dass man das ganze
einfach mit der rechten hand zocken kann
und mit der linken könnte ich mir jetzt
rein theoretisch einen aufsatz für die
uni schreiben
apropos aufsatz für die uni ich bin
derzeit dabei die facharbeit für meine
uni zu schreiben und das wäre auch was
mache ich denn jetzt was habe ich denn
jetzt bin ich jetzt geil gegessen habe
was bringen diese teile haben
irgendeinen sinn meine aktuelle länge
ist 316 das ist auf jeden fall das beste
was ich bin
je hatte und was ich sagen wollte mit
der facharbeit ich habe ja ein praktikum
gemacht über ein halbes jahres wegen
habe ich augenringe weil ich jede nacht
um zirka vier stunden schlafen konnte
allerdings wird das jetzt besser weil
wieder uni ist und was bringt es mir
wenn ich die erste den kleinen da unten
richtig ärgern weil ich war auch mal so
klein und ich will nicht dass er
gedanken von 414 ich schmeiße ist
einfach in die verfügte mülltonne ich
habe ein praktikum gemacht das war in
meinem studiengang integriert ich hab
das praktikum bei zwei unternehmen
gemacht und bin jetzt quasi wieder in
der uni und muss aber eine arbeit über
das praktikum schreiben also so was in
die richtung die ich hab das und das
gemacht und das war sehr cool und muss
mir thema habe ich schon alles
rausgesucht und so musste auch im netz
ist der dass da hinten auf was sich auf
essen wollte und muss dann quasi anhand
dieses themas untersuchen wie das in dem
unternehmen gelöst beziehungsweise
stattgefunden hat warum erzähle ich euch
das eigentlich ich weiß nicht ob es
irgendwie möglich ist dass ich zum
beispiel kleine teile von mir einfach
weg schleuder so dass andere leute
denken boku man gott ich bin noch zu
kaffee drin das vielleicht andere leute
irgendwie denken ja der will irgendwie
tatsächlich boykott gibt es mir ja man
gibt mir los
wieso ist der rotary nicht gestorben
doch freunde lanxess 600 verdammt wie
wie so weit so groß um auf das thema von
der verarbeitung zu kommen deswegen die
die schreib ich halt jetzt gerade
deswegen wundert euch nicht weshalb
vielleicht ein paar videos nicht so
bearbeitet sind die songs bearbeitet
sind ich habe
schon mal ein video gemacht wo ich das
ganz erläutert habe das heißt ja ich hab
falls ich mal wie das heißt also
deswegen kommen nicht so oft diese
übergänge mit keyframes wo ich an meine
fans kamran summe und eine bewegung
vorhanden ist und der ganze kag sondern
auch mein gott da kommt natürlich schon
der nächste an wundert euch da nicht oh
mein gott danke danke danke ich bin ein
viel zu freundlich 766 das ist der grund
warum nicht so viel bearbeitung der
verfahren ist wahrscheinlich noch mehr
bearbeitung als man es von anderen
gaming youtube kennt aber für meine
verhältnisse tatsächlich eher weniger
was macht der blöd kopf meine
verhältnisse eher weniger bearbeitung
scheiße ich dachte damit kriege ich den
abreiteplatz der respekt und bot ist der
riesige 2300 habe ich gerade als länge
das ist ja ultra krass ey ich war hat
mir eigentlich ziel gesetzt ich will
noch einmal über 1000 kommen so das wäre
schon ganz geil aber das ist jetzt echt
schon sehr cool
scheiße 1413 alt aber das ist schon echt
gut für meine verhältnisse an dieser
stelle würde ich das videos allerdings
auch beenden
weil ich tatsächlich noch viel weiter
schreibt muss aber noch vorbei das tut
mir unglaublich leid und wieder
vielleicht kurz ist also ist meine
normale luca länger eigentlich jedes
video hier wenn es euch gefallen habe
ich meine bewertung freund findet er
spekuliere ich glaube tatsächlich nicht
weil es noch sehr wenig und sehr
eingeschränktes funktionsmöglichkeiten
gibt aber man kann's immer meter
kopfballspiel vielleicht noch sich
entwickeln viert ich wollte euch auf
jeden fall mal zeigen und dann sehen wir
uns vielleicht demnächst wieder bei
atari oder blätter